one of the stats you gave which I was
like
whoa you said there are more adult
diapers being sold in Japan than baby
diapers yes already yes
and it's been like that for quite a
while actually that is terrifying isn't
it yes
um
so you know I live in Japan and the
reason I'm there is because I'm
passionate about this issue I'm actually
passionate about trying to help save
Japan uh one of the great things there
is that everyone in Japan intensely
knows about this topic
um it's on the media every day the
government are you know making uh
regular you know policy changes to try
and address it so it's a place where I
hope if anywhere in the world can solve
it it might be Japan first
um because you're right another
statistic
um in Japan
this data goes back a few years but
within the last five to ten years the
average number of people waiting for a
care home was around 400 000 people
when you get to an age in Japan of
needing a character you can't take care
of yourself you're living alone
that is the moment you can put yourself
on the list to wait for karon so you
need a care home but you can't be on the
list until you need it why because there
aren't enough Caravan spaces the average
time I think from then to wait on the
current place is three years
so you've got people you literally are
unable to take care of themselves and
able to address themselves and able to
do anything living for three years
before that place in the care home opens
up Japan is a template for much of
Europe
let me say it here I haven't said this
before but um I'm from the UK originally
I didn't have a vote here but
um because I don't live here but I I'm
pro-brexit
and at the time of brexit
um I you know contacted some newspapers
here to say look I think we should do a
an article using some of the maps I've
created to show how Grim the situation
is in Germany Italy Spain much of Europe
because people need to know just how
fast Europe's going down the hill
economically as well as in terms of the
care of the elderly there
and uh I I use the slogan if you like I
was using the term it's safer to be out
because of what's going to happen in
Europe with this rapid aging of all
people that that's already well underway
and um so it's not just Japan it's it's
on our you know or on your Shores here
in the UK
um and it's catching up so much so fast
in so many parts of the world and I
think what people probably haven't been
able to quantify but it's undoubtedly
the case is an aging Society changes uh
everything it changes whether people
start businesses or not it changes
whether there's innovation in in society
because as we all know that once you get
to a certain age you you become less
flexible and less willing to take a risk
I mean that's why young people are much
more risked hungry because that's the
time you're supposed to be trying things
because you've got time to fail you've
got time to make a mistake you've got
time to do that economically militarily
I mean it just seems to me that this is
a huge issue as I said to you at the
beginning that people don't even
understand the implications of let alone
the implications of the implications the
second order third order fourth order
consequences yeah I we haven't gone into
too many of those but just a very
obvious one is that we're going to have
too much housing for the the number of
people in our societies and today in the
UK that's probably hard to understand
because there's seen it seemed to be the
other way around at the moment but that
will change and you know these are
societies therefore that will have
decaying communities where houses will
become desolate
where communities will become desolate I
feel young people will mostly move away
from those communities I think certain
towns will become what they call magnet
towns that people gravitate towards
mostly younger people which become quite
expensive the older people will be left
in the decaying towns without enough
Health Care taxes are going to vote for
everybody and then you take National
debts so most countries Japan certainly
all countries I want to say have got
significant National debts and these
tend to get larger rather than smaller
well if you have a shrinking Workforce
to pay the interest on those I mean
you're going to have a real pressure on
the younger people
continue to have anything like the
quality of lifestyle that we have we've
had before
so communities are going to look
different
um and yeah
um
I I really worry about loneliness and
all of this you know we haven't used
that word yet but that is a core word
that I think that we need to apply uh
it's not the right word
people who don't find a partner people
who don't have children when they want
to their children
um are likely to face a level of
loneliness and there's many support
groups online already for this you can
see you can read the stories you can
even read the stories I imagine after
this podcast you'll see comments uh
coming up but people in this situation
who you know who who left it too late
dealing with a level of loneliness but
then you take older people so there's a
community in Japan where I visited where
50 years ago it was filled with younger
families and today it's only older
people but it's mainly older women
living there alone because Partners men
tend to die younger so you have this
situation where we went to the local
grocery store and they we hear that
these women come out maybe once a week
to do the shopping and they're spending
forever talking whilst they're paying
for their groceries because that's the
only person they're getting to talk to
weekly and we've got to do something
about this clearly we can't let people
remain in their Apartments without a
sense of community but we're gonna have
to think about so many issues so many
problems that come out of this that
we're not scratching the surface of yet
foreign